so then there's this there's this test
here which is you know
this is another you know it's funny this
let me open this up and show you this is
a really nice
test it's another antigen test works the
exact same way as this essentially
but what you can see is it's got like
lights in it and a power button and
stuff this is called a loom test
which is you know fine
and it's a really nice test to be honest
but it um
but it has to pair with an iphone and
and so it's good as
i think that this is going to become
this is there's a lot of use for this
from a medical perspective you know
where you want good reporting this can
because it pairs with an iphone
uh it can immediately send uh
send the report to a department of
health whereas these paper strip tests
that
they're just paper they don't report
anything unless you want to report it
okay so i'm going to just pick it up and
pick it apart and so you can see
is there's like fluorescent readers and
little lasers and leds and stuff in
there
you can actually see the lights going
off wow and there's a paper strip test
right inside there but you can see that
there's like a whole circuit board and
and all this stuff right and so
this is the kind of thing that you know
the fda is looking for
um for like home use and and things like
that because it's kind of foolproof
like you you can't go wrong with it it
pairs with an iphone so you need
bluetooth so it's going to be more
limited it's a great test don't get me
wrong it's as good as any of these
but you know when you compare this thing
with a battery
and a circuit board and all the stuff
it's got its purpose but you know it's
not a public health tool
i don't want to see this made in the
tens of millions a day yeah and thrown
away
um this is that's ga likes that kind of
stuff fda loves this stuff you know
because they can't get it out of their
mind that this is a public health crisis
you know we need
we need i mean just look at the
difference here something like flashing
lights is essential it's got batteries
it's got a bluetooth thing
it's a great test but you know it's to
be honest it's not
any better than this one yeah and so
you know i i want this one um it's nice
and all
the form factor is nice but and it's
really nice that it goes to bluetooth
but it goes against the principle of
just uh 20 million a day
exactly the easy solution everybody has
it you can manufacture
and probably you could have probably
scaled this up in a couple of weeks
oh absolutely these companies i mean the
rest of the world has these
they can be scaled up they already exist
you know sd biosensors one company is
making tens of millions a day
not coming to the united states but
going all over europe going all over
southeast asia and east asia so they
exist the us
is just you know we can't get out of our
own way
you